ينورنا في الاستديو والفنان جميل حمود
الخضر حمود اهلا بك يسعد صباحك شكرا على
تواجدك معانا صباح العربيه رغم انه عندك
مشوار سفر شكرا
في استديو صباح العربيه مش اول مره في
البرنامج
طلعنا معكم من الكويت اكثر من مره لكن
نتشرفنا نكون معكم
فنان قدره الفن الراقي على جذب الجمهور
حدثنا عنك
فنان اعتقد يبحث عن نقطه تتميزه عن همم
انا من البدايه يمكن همم كان عندي اهتمام
بطرح مواضيع مختلفه عن الموجوده في السوق
همم السوق عندنا الفني في الوطن العربي
العاطفيه هي يعني
مهم تكون موجوده لانها اقوى المشاعر هي
مشاعر العاطفه والهدف من الاغنيه
والموسيقى انها توصل مشاعر لكن ايضا لقيت
لنا فيه مساحه كبيره من المواضيع
نادرا ما يطرق لها الفن العربي
مواضيع حياتي اجتماعيه
قلت اجربها والحمد لله لقينا فيه يعني
اقبال كبير من الجمهور عليها محمود سمعنا
انه انت من اصعب الطلبات اللي بتنطلب في
حياتك انك تفيق بكير فيحنا يعني احنا
بنقدر كثير وجودك معنا هون في الاستديو
بهذا الساعه المبكره من الصباح
بس من الاغاني
بس انا عندي كمان سؤال اذا حمود هل حمود
يؤمن بالحب يؤمن بالرومانسيه هل سنرى حمود
الخضر في اغنيه رومانسيه في المستقبل لا
الاغاني الاجتماعيه ذات الرسائل
ههه
بالحب اؤمن بالرومانسيه همم وعلى صعيد
الاغاني ممكن تشوف لي نشوف لي يعني او
اغني اغنيه عاطفيه اذا قدرت اترحب بزاويه
مختلفه وغير مكرره اطرحها من زاويتي يكون
فيها يعني همم قيمه يعني قيمه معينه
قدمت عشرات اغاني السنجل شو السر اغنيه
سينجل عندك خصوصا انه ساهمت في زياده
شعبيتك وكان لها ملايين المشاهدين يعني
انا اعتقد الان نمط الاستماع الجمهور
للموسيقى
خلال الانترنت في اليوتيوب ولا في تطبيقات
فالواحد صار يسمع بس الاغنيه المفضله
بالنسبه له
فاعتقد نمط السنجل مع نمط استخدام او س-
يعني استماع الجمهور صار افضل من من فكره
طرح البوم مع ذلك كان عندي البومين يعني
احسن لكن اعتقد الجاي معظم راح يكون سنجلز
اهم وان شاء الله بالتوفيق دائما في اللي
جاي وحتى بالح
اضر بالعاده دائما الهدف الاساسي من
الاغاني والغنى هو الترفيه بس حمود ذهب
ابعد من ذلك هل كان الموضوع مخطط له ولا
جاء بالصدفه في حياتك
في المجال الفني من السنه ما اقدر اقول
انه من البدايه كان مخطط
يمكن بدات انه كان طلب مني اغاني اللي
حفلات تخرج
همم يعني همم الاغاني تخرج معانيها تكون
عن الطموح عن العزيمه همم اللي لفتني انه
صارت هذه اغاني التخرج تستخدم
الى ان كانت الهويه الفنيه محمود حنسمع
لمقطع من اشهر اغاني كن انت ونرجع لك
[موسيقى]
جوهرنا هنا في القلب تلالالا
نرضي الناس بمالا نرضاه لنا حاجه
جمالنا
يسموا يتعالى
[موسيقى]
طيب كن انت شو سر نجاح حال كبير يعني يا
محمود والله يمكن من اصعب الاسئله
تسالينها اي فنان لما تقولي لنا تقول لنا
بنضب تصير نجاح الاغنيه لان صعب انك تتحدث
كل واحد من الجمهور عنده سبب معين في ناس
عجبتهم عجبهم اللحم صح والموسيقى في ناس
عاجبهم الموضوع او الكلمات همم فيصعب علي
انا اعتقد اعتقادي يمكن بدرجه الاولى هو
اللحن والموسيقى خصوصا لان هذه الاغنيه
تحديدا انتشرت في في بلدان ما تتكلم
العربيه
انا بدي اسالك واسال نفسي يعني هل فعلا لا
نحتاج المال
نعم لكن ما نحتاج المال على الاطلاق لا
اكيد نحتاج المال حتى نعيش يعني لكن هو
الموضوع الاغنيه
كانت عن السياق الجمال الداخلي اللي هذا
اللي ما نحتاج المال
كله
طبعا انا قلت لكم قبل الهواء يعني الصوت
اليوم
ههه تصدق
مرحبا وسهلا كل من محله هذا العالم وسعبت
انا واحلى زينا المباني حققنا الاماني عيش
اللحظه معنا ودندني ودان داني الملعب
جمعنا يلا غنوا معنا نغمه عربيه
هيا هيا هيا هيا
ويلا تهيا بسم الله ابتدينا يا مرحب وحيه
هيا هيا هيا الحلم بسمانا وعلى الوعد جانا
يلا نلعب سويا
اغنيه
حمود كمان بنشيل انه انتم عملته على
نسائها النسخه المغربيه ديمه مره
بعد نزول الاغنيه بكم اسبوع ومعانا نجاح
المنتخب المغربي اللي نحييه ونحيي كل
جمهور المغرب كنا راح رايحين مباراه
المغرب والبرتغال انا وزميل الفنان ماهر
زين اللي فازوا فيها وصلوا بعدها نصف
النهائي فرجينا لازم نسوي شيء خاص للمنتخب
المغربي والجمهور المغرب فحولنا على نفس
اللحن كتبنا كلمات مع الشاعر سمير المجاري
من المغرب شاعر غنائي معروف كتبنا الكلمات
وعملنا اغنيه ديما مغرب على نفس الحلويات
وكيف كانت تجربه الفنيه
يعني من من كل اعتقد كل الفنانين الحريصين
يشاركون كلهم مشاركه في حدث عالمي نفس حدث
كاس العالم وخصوصا هالمره قاعد يصير في
البلد عربي همم انا كان عندي رغم في عمل
ماهر كان عند الرغبه من هنا صارت فكره
انها ليش ما نعمل دويتو همم والحمد لله
كانت يعني علاقه اصداء جميله
شلون راضي
عنك
اشوفك بين اعذاري ولحظات التواني اشوفك
بين اسراري وتحقيق الاماني وكم مديت لك
حبل الرجاء مني واناديك
مستنيك انا مليت تسويتي ومن بكره لبكره
وكم كشكوله خلصته ولا انجزت فكره ولي امل
بحكيها تعال اطلع واحاكيك مستنيك
مستنيك على نار الامل يا انا منهم قذاتي
ومستنيك متى تطلع الى الكون وتنور حياتي
ومستنيك ولك مني الذي يا زين يرضيك يرضيكي
مستنيك
[موسيقى]
رجل يغني لاي امراه هاك هذا الكلام طيب
جديدك ومشاريعك بعدين اغنيه المونديال
بعض الاغاني السنجلز في عمل بالمصري اول
مره باللهجه المصريه
وفي يعني كم عمل اخر نعلل عن تفاصيل ان
شاء الله في وقت بس لانه محتاجين وقت
شكرا والله دايما يعني شكرا على الاستضافه
وشكرا دائما معي في مشوار الفني في اي عمل
همم جديد يعني دائما انتم تتواصلون
وحريصين على سبق الفني وايضا تحيه
لجميلاتنا همم اشواق دائما حريصه على انه
يكون معكم في هذا البرنامج